happy glorious monday it's day one of
our second week of the no audience shows
i guess we really should lower ticket
prices this is getting ridiculous
well it's one of the great moments in
education apparently a mother in texas
has been accused of putting her son who
tested positive for covid in the trunk
of her car to prevent him from or her
from being exposed to his virus
so that's kind of awesome throwing your
kid in the trunk of your car like a set
of jumper cables
you know i think we finally found a
woman who can beat julie banderas for
mother of the year
now she faces charges of child
endangerment the woman in texas not
julie but don't give up yet
don't give up yet banderas it could
still happen for you yeah still tonight
but after she received after she arrived
at the coving tested site with her 13
year old boy in the back of her car that
raised some concerns according to the
arrest warrant she brought her son to
the drive-through site told the director
health services that her brat was in the
trunk so she wouldn't get exposed while
driving when the police were alerted the
kid was in the trunk he was freed
unharmed no word if the kid's name is
jack
just looked over at catch he doesn't
know what i'm referring to now you might
think you know let's hope this lady's
not around other kids
which is what you usually think about
when you're talking about cnn producers
but here you'd be wrong she's a high
school english teacher but has now been
placed on administrative leave which
means she gets paid to watch the
hallmark channel
and worse this trend of isolation in odd
places seems to be catching on
hey can i go home yet i've been here 14
days
i tested negative
he likes it
so this is where a shallow talk show
host might exploit this sad story as an
example of how bad our education his
system has become well i'll tell you
what i am that shallow talk show host
our education system sucks
the fact is we're living in a time where
teachers unions are happily sacrificing
the education health and safety of
children in order to protect themselves
they claim it's too dangerous to go back
to class and that would be true if we
were talking about the violence but
they're not they're using covet as an
excuse to lounge at home watching the
view day drinking until joy starts
looking human meanwhile for the fourth
consecutive day chicago public schools
have canceled classes as unions refuse
to agree when to bring the teachers back
into the classroom even though everyone
from nurses to cashiers to truck drivers
to exotic dancers julie have been back
at work for months
some of us doing all four of those jobs
in the same day
but maybe the teacher staying at home is
a good thing right if there's anything
we got out of remote learning it's that
a student's chances of learning is
remote and why is that well our
education system is the only system
exempt from the one tool that makes all
of us better that's competition
well our education system and late night
talk show hosts thanks to me there's
really no competition there either
patting myself on the back but my arms
are short
lacking competition the schools and
their unions are free to do whatever the
hell they want students be damned and if
your family doesn't like it you can't
take your business elsewhere imagine if
this kind of mentality existed in other
arenas not just public schools well in
fact it does see the department of motor
vehicles or cuba neither are known for
their short lines and highly motivated
workforce the fact is when you only have
one choice to pick from that choice
benefits the entity that's offering it
it's like being the best looking man at
fox news
it's not that you're handsome but you're
handsome by default
or maybe you live in a small town with
only one cable company good luck if it
goes out during a storm the cable
company will be in no rush to fix it
because well who are you gonna go to if
you're unsatisfied but if there are two
cable companies it's amazing how much
faster it
gets done now instead of waiting for the
cable guy from 9am to 10pm they got it
down to 9am to 8pm
and that's the public school system for
you they can abandon your kids because
where are you gonna go teach them
yourself with that hour you have free
between your day job as a cashier at
walmart or your night job stripping at
nude prudes
politicians don't care they work to
defeat school choice while enjoying that
choice for their sniveling offspring
yeah their precious buffy gets decent
instructors and actual books to read
instead of metal detectors mask mandates
and barely literate teachers who can't
be fired but to our leaders a bad
education is like high crime if it's not
their problem then it's no problem at
all well it's time to change that as one
famous democrat said never let a crisis
go to waste i believe it was britney
spears
and even she knows more about education
she's 40 years old and still fits into
her catholic school girl outfit
that's something we both have in common
but the pandemic has exposed an
educational system in crisis so this is
a perfect time for a new movement a
parental tea party that stops paying
into systems that poison your children
intellectually while the teachers sit at
home poisoning themselves with doritos
it's time to fund the students and not
the schools and then the schools will
fight for the students money but deny
those school boards your tax cash and
watch them wither and drop away like a
frozen wart from bette midler's neck
competition will make all schools and
all teachers better they may not want it
the way your kid didn't want spinach but
it wasn't up to him so let's jam it down
their throat and watch the benefits take
hold competition makes it so it's not up
to them it's up to you the parent and
that's the only solution we really have
left aside from locking kids in the
trunk of a car with their laptop and a
bag lunch
which is my kind of homeschooling
let's welcome every year tonight's guess
she's more tank than the dolphins at sea
world fox news anchor julie bandera
his favorite colors are red white and
blue up some terrorists conservative
candidate for congress in florida corey
mills
he's the funniest comedian we could get
on short notice writer and comedian joe
devito
[Applause]
and she's got a case of the mondays and
a case of expired wine coolers fox news
contributor cat tip
so julie first of all how was your dr
how's your dry january going
well we're on what what is this january
8th it's january 11th right january 10th
oh crap is it really jay rett god we're
all high i didn't even yeah i had i
don't know i started on the third
because the first couple days were rough
yes and then i it expired last night oh
okay i'm gonna start it again though
today there you go i haven't drank since
like this morning that's fantastic yeah
that's fantastic what was your tipple of
choice uh vodka and orange juice heavy
on the vodka light on the orange juice
whenever i think of good parenting i
always think of you first
do you think this woman is unfairly
maligned for keeping herself safe from
her child she sounds pretty
narrow-minded because you know you got
to think outside of the box as a parent
you know don't limit it to just the kids
i mean you could fit so much in my car i
have an suv yeah so i would fit in the
husband
the barking dogs the dirty laundry and
i'm not referring to my dark past i'm
talking about the actual filthy clothes
that are just piling up because i don't
do laundry so yeah i mean just think
outside the box and i think it's an
absolutely great idea you don't want to
expose yourself to your kids i'd like to
lock them in there for the uh the
remainder of the school year if they
come back to remote schooling that's the
reason why my dry january sucked yes i
get it i get it calling it a dry january
it was five whole days that was a dry
weekend in january that's actually good
joe do you think this is this story this
microcosm of this woman is more just an
example of how the covered panic has
just changed people freaking people out
so they're like
she i mean she actually put her kid in
the trunk of a car because she panicked
over covid yeah and if you'd heard that
she'd done that to a dog people would
have gone berserk yeah that is true if
she'd done that to a stuffed animal yes
people would have come out of her and
it's it's a stupid thing to do because
if you're that worried your choices are
kid in the trunk or the ski rack and ski
rack it's fresh air that is true i think
that's called the mitt romney
exactly and people went nuts because he
he had a dog any carrier yeah and he
lost the presidency because of that
exactly binder's full of women which we
don't even understand why that yes yes
so yeah this is um this is one of those
news stories i've noticed this weird
pattern that i'll
hear the the story you see this the
headline and i'll think it's going to be
a teacher yeah it's going to be a
teacher these teachers they got too much
time on their hands and
i think teachers have gone through this
erosion of confidence that we've seen
for doctors and politicians you used to
think someone's a teacher teachers
change people's lives and then you see
some blue-haired lunatic having a crying
fit on tick-tock and you think maybe we
go back to slates and chalk you know
what that's a really good point in that
tick tock has taught me more about
education because all i see are teachers
like saying really weird stuff on there
you know what i mean they're like
they're like you know what i taught my
kids what my gender is you know i am
genderfluid it's like no you're not
supposed to be actually doing that and
thank you tiktok for showing me these
people are crazy
corey uh how do you feel about the whole
school choice thing about the there's a
movement going on now to separate the
money away from the schools and let the
money follow the student and uh you're
running for you're running for office
where do you sit on this well i'll tell
you one of the things that's been a
problem for years is that congress has
just continued to write blind checks you
know we put billions and billions of
dollars into cobra prevention all these
schools and yet we're still being shut
down and the
school boards have been able to run
autonomously without any parental input
so my whole thing is that you're not
incentivizing these schools to make the
right choices you're not incentivizing
them to be better or for these teachers
to actually teach you're enabling them
to have this type of indoctrination and
shut down what they want because they
have ultimate control so i believe in
the idea that the money should follow
the child it shouldn't be based on if
you live in a certain neighborhood or
you have a certain community that you're
in that you're forced to go to these
schools it should really be about what
is best for your child and i think that
when you do this it encourages schools
to say oh wait a second we don't have
any money yeah we're having to lay off
people now we need to improve our
educational systems we can get kids to
come back to our schools and that's
where we need to be at and it turns the
parent into the customer just the way it
should be with everything else in life
you're a customer that you
you need to be um you need to be
attracted to the thing and they don't
have to attract you if they already got
your money you've already paid for it
any time cat that you've already paid
for something like you know an all what
do you call that an all uh
all-inclusive thank you joe you've been
to club med with me
like an all-inclusive thing and you show
up and then the service is bad because
you already paid for the service
right
i have seen that happen
i haven't seen that happen before yeah i
mean that's we have obviously we need
more options for schools i just think uh
the government couldn't be doing a worse
job i mean i don't have kids and i like
i don't know if i ever will if this
continues because like you don't want to
spend that much time with them no like
you're not supposed to spend that much
time with them i mean like i've been
around kids before yes and
like it that's been enough so far so i
can't imagine
like how i mean if i were julie i don't
know if i would have been able to do a
drive five days in january yeah no i'm
actually i'm really proud of myself do
you think that the cause of alcoholism
are children i think i think we should
pin that on kids yeah
let's put me on record saying i actually
drink more now than i did in my 20s so
yes there you go see that's the thing is
and you only had four kids in your 20s
and i'm only 35. yeah
alcohol often is the cause of children
though that is true in that direction oh
my god that's so true all right we gotta
go hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else